oh no what happens if we don't meet the
quota oh oh yeah I wait there's what's
that oh oh my God oh my God what was
that I didn't called Tri triple we got
in there early enough to where things
weren't going horrible wait does that
matter I'm saying the more you wait the
more come out to play
4.99 okay I don't think we're making
that in one day boys anybody see a
valve oh my god oh man oh my God so
young all right you SC ahead you see
what's up there I I'll figure out oh oh
my God oh my God get to the next room
close the door what if they open the
door I don't think they can uh you're in
charge now uh what do we do what do we
do what do we do what do we do what do
we do to the next room go again
run what do we do to the next
can't
run oh God oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my
God jump bro
moves oh my God oh my God run run run
run run run I can't run anymore goodbye
friend
oh hey Mark
hi did you see my cool moves on that
thing yeah you almost got away from it
yeah I juked it pretty good that's an
unfortunate creature to run to there's
not many places to go yeah yeah is that
the one that takes three swamps yeah oh
yeah and then we go up yeah yeah you can
SW it so we can buy
um Jesus [__] Christ oh wow oh oh my
God that thing is so
f
holy God so uh you and Mark found what
we call a
thumper okay and then you got killed by
the the fun coil head mannequin guy I I
heard footsteps for like half a second
before it just ConEd me yeah that that
was quick um so that didn't go well and
I have a feeling every time we go to
that place it doesn't go well so we
should go back the one we got all the
good loot from before isn't it we got
the from vow before yeah Vow where we
were no it was offense wasn't it no that
was off yeah that was offense we're
going to try again I'm not trying to say
that I'm a coward or anything but I was
just saying that like that place usually
doesn't go good you put some good moves
on that thing yeah I I juked it hard Bob
you should have seen we did have a
weapon I didn't know we had one of these
oh yeah Mark you really you really saved
my life well for a little bit so there's
a big gaping hole in the middle those
lights across the way are the main
entrance we can go right or left to get
there I did just buy some more walkies
and flashlights okay if you guys want or
need wait a second if you already have
you can go in if you want there's only
like three or four fire exits on this
map there's a lot of fire exits that
sounds great I love that I don't know if
I'm the one who should get the shovel I
don't yeah I don't know you put it in
the storage if you don't feel
responsible all right do we want to have
someone in the ship this time or do we
want to just go for it let's go for a
first run then then ship it from there
do you want me to show you guys how to
use this no we don't have time we should
have done that before explain it during
the Panic of whatever start to happen
yeah okay all right I'm going to show
you one thing over here on the left
uh-huh you see this like lighter
concrete yeah yeah that's one of the
fire exits right there oh that's
convenient okay good so if there's
something bad in the front it's uh
that's there or just if you're like if
you find a lot of Loot and you don't
want to go around a million mazes you
can try different exit to see if like
there's loot closer to the entrance okay
that sounds
good walk this thing really looks like a
face all right exploring left yes we got
something right here got a big axle got
to drop that
outside go to the right I guess all
right yeah I got left big
axle I got a big axle
boy got kind of a open room
[Music]
here got a big
bolt and I think I found that other fire
exit it's up here on the left let me
check it okay it might come out a
different spot there's a few of them on
this map all right let me see are the
same
room no I think it's the one to the left
of the entrance so so the internal
schematics are matching the external
left is to the left fire
exit got
it I'm going to take that large axle and
Big Bolt back the
ship there's three of them out
there there's a turret over here
all right Mark when you get back to the
ship can we work on turning off the
turret uh some oh spiky spiky bad spiky
man Shadow Man back spikes Shadow
SP down this hallway don't go cuz it
turrets to the left turret to the left
Mark you
live yeah sorry I just don't know how to
use my hands and do that okay what do
you need H5 so go to the computer
observe me and turn off the turret near
me so uh on the on the terminal view
terminal
type the type the phrase view space
monitor
okay
okay you should see a map on the
terminal now is that right yeah yeah
okay there's two red dots in front of
you by the way that doesn't look good so
if I type H5 it turns off
right yeah yeah there's a red
dot wait is being wait Bob I left wait
to
trouble wait is still
alive whoa I don't know what happened
but this thing is dragging Wade through
walls so he might not still be
alive oh there's bugs in here as well
there's two different kinds of
slime do you know how to change view uh
it's either view view change or
something like
that
oh
damn it Mar do you want help no no no
no here we go load back to the ship I
got I got got
it okay I got it okay Wade is definitely
dead I'm viewing you now I figured out
how to do
that um I want to tell you straight up
his body is unrecoverable how
unrecoverable
extremely like it dragged him so far
through the map deep inside it it just
pulled him into
nowhere uh there's one more axle right
yeah yeah okay I would not recommend
going in because that thing launched at
him grabbed him he was dead before like
he could do anything and then pulled him
deeper in so got it don't go in where
spiky man is yeah I don't even think
that was spiky
man
oh no wait watch out there's red right
near
you oh you know oh you know don't you
that's tree
man wait wait are you
dead oh no
[Music]
Bob oh no oh where's your body
oh no this is completely unhelpful okay
um oh
[__] oh freaking [__] ah
[__] [__]
[__] oh
[__] oh [__] okay so it says to the down
that way does that mean that way oh
[__] oh
[__]
oh
[__] where
what wait
what
what what
no oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my
God oh my
[Music]
go
oh my
God oh my
God oh my God no no oh my God oh my no
God oh
no oh I was so close
you were in the doorway I was right
there
no did it keep any of the stuff no we
lose it all and the stuff in the ship
too yep it's all gone oh but I was right
there oh man just so you know you and
Bob died to different things outside
what do you mean I not di to tree man I
died to a a dinosaur thing that ate me
what oh my God of the day we were about
to have a hell of the day why didn't
should I have just left because I didn't
know it's 50/50 some sometimes like in
hindsight yes at the time it didn't make
a wrong decision because I thought what
was on the ship would stay that's why I
dumped all the stuff inside oh that felt
bad it was a good call uh just
unfortunately just didn't work out but
it one it was 1 second away wasn't I
yeah pretty much yeah oh
man
Get the Hell in here I'm just going to
get the hell in there there yeah this is
f dud yeah yeah to the right let's
freaking go let's freaking go dude this
is going to be the one who who else has
a walkie I do not I nope okay so I'm the
walk I think you should probably just
leave that in the ship man my heart was
going on that one I don't know about oh
I'm alone all
right o
got
bottles well this is
ominous oh
boy [__]
[Music]
hello
hello the right side's done there's
nothing on the right from the entrance
there's a heavy fog
here hope there's no Landes up this time
oh good oh oh we got an old
phone that has some value that's
actually got some good
[Music]
value
okay okay we got a toy Cube that's got
some decent value too
wow
oh
nice oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God
what in the [__] get away get away get
away get away get away get away get away
no oh my
God oh my
God hey guys be careful
ful
guys be careful there's something in
there
what
what oh my
God this game is messing with me anybody
in the
ship guess
not
[Music]
okay what the freak
all right
whatever H man this game messes with you
this game really really messes with
you I haven't heard from the boys in a
bit I swear to God if the last words I
said to them were be
careful oh this why is the bridge moving
so much cuz I'm so heavy
okay see seem to be
alive
hello hey I think we still need like a
$150 $200 worth of stuff I got maybe
like 70
here hey yo uh this was a good haul um
you want me to watch over you
guys yeah OverWatch is probably a good
idea right now okay nothing red near you
guys oh you're not even inside are you
all right so the call is going to be if
you guys don't make it I am going going
to launch the ship to try to salvage as
much
money that's good
Mark there are Reds around you red
coming on the
catwalk there's another red in the
hallway down there there's a big red at
the far end of the
hallway oh God oh God Bob's gone think
Bob's dead Bob's dead Bob's
dead I I think the interior is way too
hostile
okay the other big red was a blob but
yeah are is that those little bug things
yeah the little bug things are fine
unless you pissed them off uh is there
any red near Bob's body right now uh
yeah the little bug is waiting by his
body almost like an ambush it seems to
have dragged it away and placed it and
is waiting for it do you see any yellow
triangles let me let me switch to
[Music]
you uh nothing by you but you are near
his body weirdly enough his body is oh
it might be dead hallways but
technically that catwalk if there was a
door at the far end it would lead to his
body okay I just need to find triangles
right
now all right I'm not sure what you mean
by triangles but you've got nothing on
the radar near you you'll see yellow
triangle shapes blob coming up left
behind you down the long hallway there's
a blob that's crawling up that
way okay uh can you kind of guide me
where Red Red Dot Dead Ahead far end ran
the opposite
direction can I zoom out on this map or
is this it that's
it all right Red Dot is coming up that
long hallway be careful it's the
bug okay I see no
triangles another Red Dot different one
coming up behind
you yeah one there's you're now
uh surrounded by red
dots and okay I'm just I don't know if I
have time to find much more I I don't
think you do you were about to be nabbed
so I'd say just get back to the ship and
let's uh maybe we could sell back our
flashlights for enough we got a shovel
too and the boom
box I got a tree man is there any way I
could lure
him I don't think so I don't think the
boom box works on these guys he needs
visual okay did you come up the fire
exit yes I've only got one way
out all
right goodbye Mark oh no I'll miss you
was okay all right um yeah I'm just I'm
just going to
go well
um huh that's nice a check mark 4:30 uh
o so what happens that we didn't make
quota probably well I guess we'll find
out yeah uh well we might have enough we
we might have enough the uh apparatus
has question mark value so we actually
don't know what it's worth the apparatus
that's pretty good the big yellow thing
uh how do I I already so you type in
company company then confirm but I
already did it but so it shouldn't let
you but that's what you do all right
pull the lever shall we do it man this
phone has a lot of screaming on the
other end of it heard you call I didn't
call anybody I don't I don't hear
anything we're selling everything we got
right oh yeah boys yeah sell the
apparatus last to really find out if we
got what we
needed should we sell like flashlights
and stuff too
maybe cuz those are the keys have value
the stuff we buy really doesn't okay you
want to sell the keys I mean we might
need them yeah might need to sell them
or might need to sell them the boom bo
prob won't have any value something we
bought I'll put one key there to see
what it's going to
be oh God you mad you mad or something
it's not much okay well that broke did
you ding the bell I did not ding the
Bell
oh
get us to
400 okay was worth three three okay well
that's something I think that's
everything
boys what are you
doing to open the door all right I think
we're fine guys I think we yeah I I
think we're good we need what 23
something mhm um oh oh appz was 80
that's uh yeah we're at 430 right now
let's throw the boom box in let's see
what that's
worth be great zero do you think the
keys might have other values other than
opening doors are being sold no I mean
like they worth more or
less is the door open cuz it's not open
for
me
oh okay well he worth five bucks that's
something uh we got zero for it what if
one of us sells ourselves to the company
I thought we
sell really you know what here Mark grab
this for the company all do it well I
don't know if I oh man this feels so for
the
the company
theany oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
I got oh man let's see how much weight
is worth
[Music]
first I may have made it
Angry
okay five bucks five bucks okay well
Mark I think you know what you have to
do oh man I love the I don't know if
it's going to get us there uh the
company all right I love the
company all right how's that feel oh man
you you went down way quicker why was
weight so tough you went down like a zck
of potatoes yep and uh this is a fine
shovel it's been used to kill two of my
friends therefore it has emotional value
give me a good
[Music]
deal well shovel had no value to compy
oh ah
Solitude nothing else to all right here
we
goop well what's going to
happen
I bet it's
good oh hey hi we're back okay cool cool
Co keep working for the company and make
up our uh our lost funds only $59 over
so we we'll have to make that up we just
got $146 fine as you have not theit has
been deemed the
most welcome to why did we get brought
back to life for this the
[Music]
company